- We're back with Dwayne
Johnson, give it up!
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- So to celebrate the
release of his movie,
Black Adam, this Friday,
we also have a few
of his castmates joining
us now, I'm super stoked.
Please say hello to Pierce
Brosnan, Aldis Hodge,
Quintessa Swintell, and Noah Centineo.
(audience cheering) (upbeat music)
Oh my gosh!
- All right.
- Okay, so Pierce, we saw
some of your amazing art
last time, I have to bring this up.
'Cause I had no idea you were an artist
and then when you were- you
have been here physically,
but it was on Zoom.
- That's right, we were.
- Yeah.
- We were told we were doing
the Eurovision movie, I think.
- Yes, which I loved.
- We were talking about that.
Thank you. But,
Thank you.
- But, next time,
I'm gonna ask you to sing with me.
'Cause you sing well.
- I know guys- you- I mean,
I got a platinum album,
a gold album, Mama Mia.
- We didn't even ask.
- Why was I ousted here?
- I know. No-
- Maybe it's just for
the best though, Kelly.
- Wait, did you paint or draw,
like, while you were filming at all?
- I do, yes. I mean we
made this movie in Atlanta
and I had a beautiful house and a studio.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was out in the woods
somewhere and I painted.
I had a- I made about
three paintings and so,
you know, I started as a commercial artist
and wanted to be an artist
and ended up being an actor.
Thank God.
- No, you're great.
That's what I thought was-
It's funny, like, you don't know.
(audience cheering)
- Okay, go ahead, sorry.
- Anyway, no, those are
three pieces that I made
while I was in Atlanta.
You know, the helmet and these characters
that come off the the pages of my script.
I'm always drawing and
doodling in the script.
- I love that, you're
just creative all around.
I like it.
- Tries to be.
Yes
- Yes.
You are succeeding.
You're not just trying.
Well Aldis, I have to say,
so you've said that you were surprised
by Pierce's excitement over this movie.
So is he- is he still
the guy that gets so exc-
I'm still that person. I
hope I never lose that.
I get very excited about doing stuff.
Or was that like, inspiring?
- It was, well I- you know,
I was really impressed and-
by Pierce, just in general, he
is the consummate gentleman.
This brother is amazing,
know what I'm sayin?
- [Kelly] Aww.
(audience cheering)
- Two way street, two way street.
- I remember when we were on set one day
we were looking at all like, you know,
Pierce was like, oh this
is cool, this is cool.
I'm looking back at it him-
First of all we're looking like,
bro, you know, look like, like you cool.
- You're 007.
- But no- he- you know, because he was so
just gracious and enamored
with everything going on,
I was like, so how do you keep
that joy, that wonderment,
you know, that carries
throughout your career
so that you can still enjoy it?
And we had a great
conversation about that, which,
you know, gave me a little
light and taught me how
to figure out the
principles I need in order
to continue enjoying what I do.
Because this is a massive opportunity.
Obviously, we're all excited about this.
But how do you keep the same joy,
that love we have for this, going forward?
And that was just- it was monumental.
- Yeah.
- Do you- do you think it
matters to take time off?
I feel like for me the reason why-
'cause people always say like,
why are you still so exc-
I freak out when I go places.
I'm like, oh, why love
your- I'm just so excited.
I'm that person. But I
think I take time off.
Like, I get away from my job,
I'm not like, of Hollywood.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, I think that's important to do.
- Yeah, I think of myself as-
I'm definitely a businessman
and an entrepreneur.
I don't know about- I'm not
good at taking time off.
Friend told me one time,
rest is a discipline.
- [Kelly] Boy.
- Yeah.
I know, I wrote a whole song
about it, called Be Still
just 'cause I can't.
So I was like, maybe I right about it.
It'll just kinda happen. I was like, yeah.
It's very hard for me to do too.
But Noah, I wanna ask
you, so what was it like
for you getting to work with this cast?
This is an awesome opportunity
to do a superhero thing as well.
That's super cool.
- Yeah, I mean, joining a
superhero world, one, is crazy.
Two, Black Adam, which has
never been explored before
in the history of the universe.
At least not in the cinematic universe,
maybe in the comics of course.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Is an honor and to join
alongside these legends
that you see on this couch and those
that were behind the camera
as well, just blew my mind.
I couldn't be more grateful to Dwayne
for putting this together.
I mean, this is a passion project of his
for the last 10 years.
And it comes through,
it came through on set,
and I think it's now a
passion project for all of us.
- Wow.
- You guys, your characters,
are so funny, man.
You're like, we are gonna
have a talk about this later.
Like, it's like amazing.
So you two bonded when you got to Atlanta
to film the movie, right?
- We do, we immediately got
coffee before we ever filmed
'cause you know we never met outside
of the chemistry read.
- Yeah.
- But even after the chemistry read,
I think it was so clear.
They called after we came
after the chemistry read
from drama was like, so it's cute, right?
I was right, yeah, okay.
We're on the same page,
cool, cool, cool, cool.
And we were Atlanta and then we-
I was like, let's grab coffee.
- Yeah.
- We hung out for 2, 3, 4 hours.
Walked around, found an art commune.
- Yeah, we just stumbled across
this art commune and like,
this railroad area and it
was such a random moment.
We were like silent for
like two minutes walking,
just looking at everything.
And then Noah just turns
to me and he's like,
who let us be superheroes?
And then we just started dying.
And that was kind of
like, the start of just
this beautiful like,
relationship and just like,
friendship, you know, with Noah.
Couldn't be more thankful for it.
- Yeah.
I would love to just
acknowledge something.
So what Quintessa just said, you know,
when they come in with just that kind of
really cool humility of like,
who let us be superheroes?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's the kind of like,
effervescence that came on set
with with these guys.
It was really just so cool to see like,
to watch these guys come
on set with that kind of
appreciation and gratitude,
but also that type of like,
holy, we're doing it.
- Yeah.
- It's amazing.
- Oh my god, and y'all like,
I have a six and eight year old.
They get so excited. It's a
cool thing to play superhero.
Like, all the ki- they literally
like, they get so excited.
You're like supernatural to the-
even though you're really just human.
Like they- it's a cool part to play like,
for a lot of kids out
there too, it's awesome.
- We showed the movie at my
house there the other week
and my boys and my stock with
my boys and all their friends
just went way up.
- It's like the first
time you've done something
amazing for them?
- Truly. They were just so blown away.
- That's so funny.
Not Bond, not-
- Not Thomas Crown Affair.
None of the things, yeah.
- No.
- Well done, Pierce, you
finally got there, buddy.
- I could see their faces
just beaming with joy for me
and for the whole movie.
They just loved it.
- Well wait, let's talk
about Dr. Fate for a minute
because what I found amazing
is the whole time I kept going,
how does one see when that's your costume?
Like, your costume has no-
- You don't see anything
- No eyes.
- Is it really, you don't see-
- No, it's just like your
putting a bucket on your head.
I mean it looks gorgeous and I did-
I mean Jaume Colett-Serra-
- He can't see.
Lucky you don't, like,
suffer from claustrophobia
or anything like that.
- No, but- well, there's two helmets,
there's the kind of ornate
beautiful helmet that I carry
and then there's this large bucket helmet
that I would put on my head, very briefly,
because I couldn't see anything.
I put it on.
- Oh my god.
- It's ridiculous.
It was- there was a point in
the movie where I transform
and it's this kind of can
and I have to reach down
and get this bag.
So, action, put it on and it's...
Sorry, sorry. Let's do it again.
- I love it, it was like
you're Doctor Fate and like,
I guess fate is in someone else's hands
'cause you can't see. I was like-
It was amazing.
Okay, so Quintessa,
you're one of the first
non-binary actors to play a
superhero in the DC Universe.
So what does that mean to you?
It's gotta feel pretty cool.
- I mean, I think, you know,
maybe I'm one of the first,
you know, I'm out.
So that's-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, that's one thing.
You know, there could be
people who are questioning
or you know, still figuring, you know,
what that means to them
and their gender identity.
But for me, I think it just-
it's an incredibly, like-
I don't like, take it lightly.
I think because as a young kid,
I never would've thought that like someone
who's non-binary or trans could be open
enough with who they are and
like, showcase who they are,
you know, globally,
and get, you know, far.
And be able to do the things
that they've always dreamt of.
And you know, just fully
just embrace who they are.
So I think being here
and like, being out and,
you know, discussing these
things and even, you know,
you asking that question is so important
because there could be
a a young trans person
or someone who's just
questioning who needs to see
themselves represented in some sort of way
just to know that they can do anything
that they dreamt of, so-
- Absolutely.
- Woo!
- Inclusivity.
(audience cheering)
Oh my gosh.
Well, Aldis, so what did the
role of Hawkman mean to you?
You're so cool. It was
like, and I loved it.
And your chemistry is so hilarious,
how y'all are fighting
- Oh, we go at it.
like a lot of the time.
- Yeah, yeah.
No, in terms of like what
it meant to me, it's-
first of all, definitely
I am a superhero fan.
I got into the game because of DC.
I just wanted to do jobs to go buy toys
and comics, you know?
So for me to be able to present Hawkman,
this titular figure, in
this way, for the first time
on a film with this amazing cast,
with the biggest God darn superstar.
(cheering)
- It doesn't get better than that, but...
for me on the back end,
even more important,
you know, much to Qs point,
being able to be a vessel in
the progressive conversation
that allows little black and
brown kids to see themselves
and see that impossible is possible.
They can never go back to thinking,
oh, I can't be a part of
that, or that's imaginary.
They now, the standard is
I'm supposed to be there.
- [Quintessa] That's right.
- And that is never gonna change.
- That's good.
- You know what, I say this
all the time on the show,
but inclusivity is important for everyone,
not just those who don't feel
like they're represented.
It's important for my
kids to see every culture,
to know every- it's
important for every kid
to see everything.
- [Quintessa] Yeah.
- [Aldis] Yeah.
- Like, it's just as important.
Because your- my kids would be missing out
on that opportunity to learn something.
- [Aldis] Yeah.
- That's important.
- What it does is, cohesively,
it allows us as a culture
to move forward towards that
progressive goal together
as a unit, which is how it should be.
- Yeah. I agree, I agree.